Lex Luthor with a hair transplant Elon
Musk just unveiled his plans to send
human colonists to Mars the proposed
spaceship would hold 100 people who
judging by every sci-fi movie would be
brilliant scientists and engineers who
are also super couple Muska musk says
the journey could take as little as 80
days unless there's traffic on the 405
and think it just takes a ball 10 but
they might as well just leave right now
they'll arrive just in time to see Trump
set the earth on fire so to pass the
time on the way to the red planet musk
has all kinds of fun activities planned
like movies zero-g games figuring out
how to build a fuel refinement plan on
Mars so you don't die alone in space all
the fun stuff the kids love but I'm sure
they're still gonna have some hours to
fill so comedians how else will these
colonists pass the time on their way to
Mars Bruce Campbell I won the game
that's the first question it doesn't I
don't you saw well this is how the
things you can do yeah I come up with a
cool quote for when they land yep cuz
right now the best thing they got is
suck hard Buzz Aldrin
hahaha big swords and floating turd
volleyball yeah buddy doesn't room
waiting for the beverage cart to go by
so you can finally p yeah oh it's
perfect